blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman we are in the middle of some
pretty historic times right now um and i
don't say that in the meaningless sort
of way oh it's historic uh the longest
war for the united states
is ending and in some sense it has ended
in the last few hours joe biden
announcing uh as well as secretary of
state anthony blinken
that the united states has flown its
final flight out of afghanistan where
the united states has been
for 20 years there are now some images
that may become
iconic or emblematic in some sense as we
go forward the associated press
reporting that the last troops have
exited afghanistan ending america's
longest war
there is this image
this night vision image
of a
military service member
um provided to the associated press
boarding a c-17 cargo plane at the
airport in kabul
yesterday
considered the final american service
member to depart afghanistan now in
reality there's usually always some
caveats like there's probably still a
few there that are maybe in a
less official capacity or not in uniform
or you never know you guys understand
what i'm saying but the point here is
joe biden is officially getting the
united states out expected to address
the nation later today i plan to cover
it live on youtube twitch and facebook
and the top line here is that this is a
major accomplishment the associated
press writing the us has completed its
withdrawal from afghanistan ending
america's longest war and closing a
chapter in military history likely to be
remembered for colossal failures
unfulfilled promises and a frantic final
exit that cost the lives of more than
180 afghans and 13 u.s service members
some barely older than the war
now there are many
who want to argue that means that it was
wrong to leave but it's really important
to understand
that if you go in
in a hair-brained ill-thought-out way as
george w bush did
and you remain for two decades
as uh failures continue to mount and you
fail to achieve
really almost anything other than the
temporary uh suppression of the taliban
why would we assume getting out is going
to go swimmingly in other words it
doesn't follow logically if it was a
disaster to get in and it was a disaster
while we were there is it a reasonable
expectation to think that the exit is
going to be ginger snaps and waterfalls
now i'm not being
coy
about the fact that lives were lost
in getting out
in the same way that lives were lost
while there all it's been some time
since american lives were lost while
there
but afghan lives have continued to be
lost there and afghan lives will likely
continue to be lost there after our
departure but the top line is that this
is a major accomplishment in that the
big arc is
george w bush got us in
it was a disaster it was a quagmire
uh barack obama failed to get us out
donald trump failed to get us out and
joe biden has gotten us out i'm not
pretending that the rest is irrelevant
it's not it's people's lives
there are things that could have been
done better
and that applies to the entire time we
were there and getting in in the first
place that's not unique to joe biden but
the big picture is i mean in 10 years
and 20 years and 30 years
what is the story of the war in
afghanistan obviously much of the story
remains to be told and it'll depend on
what happens during that period of time
but the arc is
george w bush got us in in 2001
we stayed for 20 years what the hell
were we doing and then joe biden got us
out that's the big story
and uh it is not a story that is being
told
in that clear terminology
uh in too many places now there are some
that will write in and say david it's
not being told in that clear terminology
because it's not that clear and it's far
more complicated i'm with you i'm not
pretending there isn't complexity here
but those are the big points
a little bit more from this associated
press article
hours before president joe biden's
tuesday deadline for shutting down a
final airlift and thus ending the u.s
war air force transport plans carried a
remaining contingent of troops from
kabul airport late monday thousands of
troops had spent a harrowing two weeks
protecting the airlift of tens of
thousands of afghans americans and
others seeking to escape a country once
again ruled by taliban militants in
announcing the completion of the
evacuation and war effort general frank
mckenzie head of u.s central command
said the last planes took off from kabul
airport at 3 29 pm washington time or
one minute before midnight in kabul he
said some american citizens likely
numbering in the very low hundreds were
left behind and he believes they will
still be able to leave the country
secretary of state anthony blinken put
the number of americans left behind at
under 200 likely closer to 100 and said
the state department would keep working
to get them out he praised the
military-led evacuation as heroic and
said the u.s diplomatic presence would
shift to doha qatar
jake sullivan biden's nsa said tuesday
the mission to get americans out of
afghanistan continues biden was set to
address the nation on afghanistan later
tuesday we will cover that as i
mentioned biden said in a written
statement monday military commanders
unanimously favored ending the airlift
not extending it he said he asked
blinken to coordinate with international
partners in holding the taliban to their
promise of safe passage for americans
and others who want to leave in the days
ahead
this is a very important thing
this is the right decision this was an
unwinnable intervention
and the fact that
listen
everything we've seen happen in these
two weeks proves that we shouldn't be
there the taliban so quickly taking over
control
isis so quickly
getting in and doing a suicide bombing
these are not reasons to stay
these are reasons to leave and it
doesn't mean we don't care about the
people there but the us simply can't be
the world's policeman a situation that
depends on our military presence in
afghanistan indefinitely because of
george w bush's hair brain decision is
untenable and this is correct i believe
history will bear that out with much
tragedy in the meantime there is no
denying that whatsoever and what i want
to talk about next is what's happening
with joe biden's approval rating
partially because of afghanistan but
mostly not
if like me
you've been skeptical that joe biden's
declining approval rating is actually
because of the afghanistan fiasco which
i believe is the right decision but has
had significant tragedy
within it
i believe you are completely correct it
is not because of afghanistan that joe
biden's approval rating started to
decline and today i want to talk about
why joe biden's approval rating is
actually declining now before we do that
the first question is
has joe biden's approval rating declined
never assume right i mean so if the
story is why is it declined first let's
verify whether it has declined it has
declined the answer is yes joe biden's
approval started around the mid 50s in
an average of polls when he took office
it was in the low 50s around mid-june it
is now down to an average of 47 and uh
joe biden has switched to a net
disapproval net disapproval more people
disapproving than approving
that is a decline and it's outside the
margin of error but
afghanistan is playing a role only
recently in this and part of why we know
that that's true is we understand how
time works the decline for joe biden's
approval started in late july
that was reflective therefore because it
takes a couple of days to put together
the polling data and release it and it's
based on what happened before that
because joe biden's approval rating
started declining publicly in late july
it means it was based on what was going
on in mid-july the afghanistan situation
didn't take place in mid-july it took
place in mid-august so because time
moves forward and we don't currently
have time machines that i'm aware of
something other than afghanistan started
this decline in joe biden's approval so
what is it why is it that joe biden's
approval is declining there are a number
of reasons first it is typical that
presidents come into office with higher
approval and then it goes down that's
really common why is that well the way a
lot of people think is not when asked do
i approve of the way joe biden is
handling being president most people
don't say well i agree with eight out of
ten things he's done so i approve many
people think if there is anything he's
done that i don't like i disapprove and
so over time you typically see
presidential approval ratings decline
there are instances that are different
when 9 11 happened george w bush's
approval shot up he then squandered it
by attacking the wrong country okay but
it is typical that presidents see
declining approval during their
presidency so that's a systemic reality
now in terms of what was happening
joe biden's decline in approval
coincided with the covet delta variant
search
biden's high approval early in his term
was riding on being new but also on
declining case numbers and on rapidly
accelerating vaccination thanks to
anti-vaxxers and the delta variant covet
is now exploding hospitalizations are at
a record vaccinations have slowed down
although lately they are picking back up
and biden's approval decline came right
as the case numbers went up in late june
and early july now in addition joe biden
started to really need a big legislative
accomplishment i've been talking about
this with you for a couple of months and
he has not gotten it this has put more
downward pressure on joe biden's
approval and then after months of all of
this stuff yes afghanistan imploded and
even though it was not only the correct
decision to leave but one that most
americans support the chaotic fallout
pushed biden's approval down further
uh accelerated by
um negative coverage of what was going
on in afghanistan now i also believe
that joe biden's approval is going to go
lower before it recovers if it does
because the latest polling is mostly
from before the isis suicide bombing in
kabul about five days ago i imagine that
joe biden's approval is going to get
down to the low 40s before it might
start to recover that's if there's a
recovery we don't know yet now even
though afghanistan is currently hurting
joe biden in the polling i don't think
that afghanistan will be a factor in
2022. it's a guess it's still possible
but i believe that the combination of
short voter memory combined with foreign
policy simply not impacting
elections very much particularly midterm
elections combined with it being
democrats up for re-election in 22 not
joe biden himself
i would be surprised if afghanistan
plays a major role in the midterm
elections that are now uh just about
what is it uh 15 14 months away i
actually think that it's wackier
to blame delta on biden which started
the decline in his approval
than afghanistan delta rose globally and
in some places like the u.s it's really
bad why is it so bad well because of the
anti-vaxxers who are mostly republican
because of republican governors
who states are are not doing well now i
agree that the buck stops with biden it
does but the truth is biden scaled up
vaccination biden did most things right
on the virus but republicans called it
fascism
and republican governors tried to block
many of the things that joe biden was
doing blame biden for things that are
truly his fault or at least
a result of what he's done but we know
that that's not how politics actually
works so bottom line i'm expecting a
continued decline in approval for joe
biden before it levels out but i don't
expect afghanistan to play a major role
in the 2022 midterms if you disagree
with me or you agree or you're confused
or you don't even know where you are
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
and let me know your thoughts
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
my friends i would love it if you signed
up at joinpackman.com and became a david
pakman show member today it is our
primary source of funding we want to be
primarily funded by the audience and you
can get instant access to the daily
bonus show by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com
let's get caught up on a few other
things going on republican congressman
jim jordan from ohio
suddenly remembers
another phone call with then-president
donald trump while the trump riots were
going on on january 6th now you might
remember that last month jim jordan said
he had a phone call with trump on
january 6th
he couldn't remember what they talked
about he couldn't remember whether it
was before the riots during the riots or
after the riots that's really weird
we now have a new declaration from jim
jordan who says
to politico
look
i definitely spoke to the president that
day i don't recall
i know it was more than once i just
don't recall the time so now he is
admitting
to at least two phone calls on the day
of the trump riots and it's starting to
smell it's starting to stink like a guy
who's just trying to get his story
straight for possible future testimony
now there's another funny detail here as
well
jim jordan was asked about matt gates
and whether matt gates was on that phone
call was it a so-called three-way phone
call
and jim jordan says he'd have to think
about it that's a quote have to think
about it
saying that was a hectic frenetic day
and he had many different conversations
that's also really weird you don't
remember whether it was just you talking
to trump or whether matt gates was also
on the phone that's a really strange
thing
all of this is adding up to jim jordan
as an obvious liar
i'll remind you of a couple of the clips
he's been asked this a couple of times
these are almost like instant classic
type clips here is what where brett
bayer was asking him about the phone
calls
and his he just doesn't make any sense
and you can tell bret bayer is visibly
confused by what's going on remember
this he's obviously going to go down a
number of different roads
about who knew what when who was talking
to coordinators of the protest did you
talk to the former president that day
i've talked to the former president
umpteen times thousands i mean i may not
have i mean
countless countless times i talk to the
president i never talk about what we
talk about so here is jim jordan first
just trying to avoid even saying at all
whether this is from july
first he was like i just talked to the
president he didn't even want to answer
about january 6 but bret baer pressed
him i just don't think that's
appropriate just like i don't talk about
what happens in republican conferences
so i've talked to the president numerous
times uh i continue to talk to the
president
on january 6 congressman yes i mean i've
talked to the president
i've talked to the president so many i
can't remember all the days i've talked
to him but i've certainly talked to the
president yeah okay so notice that's two
attempts and he still doesn't say on
january 6th i spoke to him and and on
that day was
can you share any of the insight of what
he was thinking about that day uh brett
the people we need to come testify are
the people who can testify to the
fundamental questions why didn't the
united states capital the people's house
have an appropriate security posture on
that day and what have we done those are
the people we need to hear from
that's the information and testimony we
need to get that's what we should focus
on but i don't think that benny thompson
the chairman of this committee said
everything's on the table so he's off on
benny thompson so that started to get
weird and then taking a cue from this
um when jim jordan appeared on spectrum
news
good for him the reporter tried to press
him on the same stuff and it was the
same type of evasive nonsense
there's some confusion over what you
told bret bear on fox news on tuesday
night so i want to clear it up first
i'll speak yes or no did you speak with
president trump on january 6th yeah i
mean i speak i spoke with the president
last week i speak with the president all
the time i spoke with him on january 6.
so here now we have an admission okay in
the time between the bear interview and
this one now jim jordan admits yes uh he
probably realizes i'm not going to be
able to avoid answering this i will
concede that we spoke on that day i
talked with president trump all the time
and that's that's i don't think that's
unusual uh i would expect defensive
members of congress
to talk with the president of the united
states when they're trying to get done
the things they told the voters in their
district to do uh i i i'm i'm actually
kind of amazed sometimes if people keep
asking this question of course i talk to
the president all the time i talk to him
like i said i talked with him last week
on january 6 did you speak with him
before during or after the capital was
attacked
uh i'd have to go i i
i spoke with him that day after i think
after i don't know if i spoke with him
in the morning or not i i just don't
know uh
so this is when we started you know the
there's a couple of possibilities at
this point right it's like well maybe
he's he's alluding to i spoke to him
more than once it was after and before
but the idea that if it was only one
phone call this was like a this was a
blockbuster event riots incited by trump
carried out by trumpists
you would remember
was
was the phone call before any of that
meaning we didn't talk about the riots
because the riots hadn't happened if the
phone call was during or after
clearly the phone call would mostly be
about the rights it's just not plausible
but this is when we started to think
maybe there were two phone calls or even
more i'd have to go back and i mean i
don't i don't i don't know uh though
that when when those conversations
happen but um
but what i know as i spoke all the time
but but taylor the key here is the
people we need to speak to okay so then
he gets back to you're not even talking
we're not even talking to the right
people you shouldn't be talking to me it
shouldn't be about me and trump so the
word conversations there raised well
maybe there were multiple calls and then
now jim jordan is admitting that that
there was more than one call so not
exactly a guy who transmits honesty
and if you're wondering why would he
want to hide the fact
uh the facts of when he spoke to trump
because if he spoke to trump during or
after the riots he would have relevant
knowledge about trump's state of mind
the reports are trump was gleeful about
the riots publicly trump had to pretend
that the riots were bad at least to some
degree even though he still said i
understand you know you're great people
and i understand why you're upset
because the election was stolen
that's why jim jordan would not want to
concede that he spoke to trump while the
riots were going on or shortly
thereafter so really something else
clearly a dishonest guy and we'll see
what ultimately comes of this
i have for you today
some this is probably my favorite video
from the last three months other than my
own interview with mike pillow mike
lindell the ceo of my pillow this is a
fantastic interview
from
australia
where sarah ferguson interviews
sydney powell
now sydney powell was one of the lawyers
going around the country
trying to legislate trump's voter fraud
claims at different points in time
sydney powell was at one point in the
oval office meeting with trump
at another point denounced or not not
denounced but uh uh
disassociated from trump claiming this
is not someone working for me this is
someone doing her own thing
this interview
is like nothing i have ever seen at one
point sydney powell just cuts the
interview
let's take a look at some of the
highlights listen to this and the what's
the point here
the point i know some people say david
don't tell us what the point is let us
watch it
look at how when we go full circle these
people who were adamant about their
claims
when they were carrying out these legal
challenges
now you can tell they never knew what
the hell they were talking about let's
take a listen look at this let's get a
few simple facts straight in how many
states were smartmatic machines and
software used in the 2020 election i
don't even know the exact numbers but
you were making some um big statements
very dramatic critical statements about
smartmatic you must have known what
their involvement was in the election no
you'd have to go look at our complaint
against with
with respect to the four states that we
filed legal complaints in to get the
details of that a google search would
have shown you that smartmatic was
operating in one single county in
california
well i'm saying i think their
involvement's probably a lot bigger than
that okay so now you start to see
sydney powell doesn't even really know
the involvement of smartmatic which was
like the centerpiece of her claims
and without evidence even after being
told the facts about smartmatics she
just says i just believe they were more
involved oh okay and is is that the type
of argument you would expect to make in
court sydney research or fact-checking
did you do at the time to find out what
smartmatics actual involvement in the
election was if you work for smartmatic
[Laughter]
you've made an allegation against
smartmatic that they stole no i'm a
journalist i'm wondering whether you
have any basis for the claims you make
presidential election i think it's
incumbent on both of us to know what
smartmatics involvement was it seems
like a pretty foundational fact i mean
i'm confused right now about why you're
here
because you may how did you get into my
house ma'am who let you in series of
very strong allegations against
smartmatic and against dominion
containing many errors of fact
do you accept the fact now that the
company that you accused of stealing a
national election only operated in one
county in la in california no one county
one state no i'm not prepared to accept
that fact i think smartmatic's
involvement was far more significant
than that do i think they're trying to
minimize their involvement of course i
do you said that smartmatic owns
dominion how do you justify such a basic
factual error
i'm gonna stop this interview right it's
wholly inappropriate in the litigation
that we're in but we're not
even in the area of great dispute these
are the simple facts of who owns what no
we're done
all right
so she gets uh
the facts when we are in litigation
against me personally
i i understand that
yes i understand that these are very
serious allegations
so
as you can tell absolutely no factual
basis for anything
she does eventually come back although
it seems almost like under protest let's
take a look at a little more
after some discussion ms powell agreed
to answer more questions yeah i'm highly
skeptical of how long this is going to
last
claiming her legal issues prevented her
from talking about the voting machine
companies
all of the organizations who had the
responsibility to
check the nature of this election and to
verify its results say there was no
fraud that's the propaganda they're
putting out i disagree with that
completely and we have and will produce
additional evidence that shows otherwise
how many years will it take to produce
the evidence they claim is coming i mean
i'm not asking it sarcastically i would
i would love to know from them do you
think we will get this in 22 2023 20
when will we get that evidence trump
says very soon very very soon um what
you're describing is a massive
country-wide fraud involving the fbi the
doj
the department of homeland security the
organizations who certify elections and
on and on all the way up to the attorney
general and thousands of local election
officials are you saying that thousands
of americans participated
in a fraud
i am saying that thousands of americans
had some role in it knowingly or
unknowingly it was essentially a
bloodless coup
where they took over the presidency of
the united states without a single shot
being fired who's they in that sentence
i i don't know who all that they are
they did it
i don't know who they are
they didn't even know they were doing it
but they did it
i would really like to know the answer
to that but it's a significant number of
they and they knew exactly what they
were doing and they planned it for at
least three years this was no accident
do you ever hear yourself and think that
it sounds ridiculous
i know i know myself very well i've been
in me a long time she has been inside of
herself long enough to know
she sounds totally normal my friends so
you know
is sydney powell delusional
is there a mental illness component here
is she just wrong
is there a financial incentive i don't i
don't think there is a financial
incentive i i ask that but i i'm pretty
sure the answer there is no
what on earth is going on with this
woman and that is just a stunning
stunning video we'll have more uh of
those clips
on the show's instagram you can find us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow and
while you're there
follow me at david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today bobby azarian who is a cognitive
neuroscientist blogger for psychology
today and also writer of the sub stack
road to omega bobby it's great to have
you back on today
thanks for having me david appreciate it
so maybe to start with you know many of
us have been seeing uh i mean we can go
back and and talk about during the
pandemic
we can talk about january 6th in many
different ways and from different people
we've been seeing behavior
that seems
disregulated at minimum and other words
that we could apply to it at worst if we
want to can you talk first from a
neuroscience standpoint what is it that
is happening when people's the way i
would as a layman say it
their common sense seems to be almost
hijacked in a sense and they behave in
ways that many of us find hard to
imagine ever behaving ourselves what is
it that's taking place
um so i guess the first thing i'd say is
that uh if we don't look at what's going
on through the lens of science in
particular psychology and more
specifically a theory called care
management theory uh we're going to be
completely lost about what's going on um
things will just seem completely random
and chaotic and unpredictable yeah and
in a sense they are certainly chaotic
but they're not
totally unpredictable so for looking at
things um from the perspective of
psychology and we look at all of the
events that have transpired since really
the emergence of trump really you can go
back farther than that then um
we see that a lot of these responses uh
were due to
um
events that call
cause existential fear in people so for
example um trump the emergence of trump
himself was a response to fears over
isis and fears over immigration um when
trump
took power then for uh
people on the left their fear was having
a incompetent leader um that stokes
division um then the pandemic hit and
there's like it's it's the biggest form
of existential fear we're all freaked
out so when you have those conditions uh
basically uh that fear creates uh
certain psychological effects that uh
promote tribalism uh that make us uh
more aggressive towards people who don't
share our world view and
once that process happens it's very hard
to reverse that because there are
certain
psychological phenomena
like something i can talk about in a
minute called amygdala hijack where
basically um we're controlled by our
fears we're sort of programmed rather
than being these rational thinkers and
uh once this happens one side uh
becoming more extreme uh polarizes the
other side that's trying to balance that
and then you get on this trajectory
where you're going towards uh just a
more uh divisive
state and so if you don't do something
to get a hold of that uh basically you
we're headed towards disaster so let's
think a little bit like for example when
i hear you say that a lot of this can be
triggered when uh we're around people
that don't share our world view and it
creates creates this lupine cycle with
something like the anti-vaccine
anti-mask protests
i'm not seeing
the pro-vaccine and pro-mask people
behave the same way as the anti although
in in some general sense maybe it would
happen because both are being
challenged in terms of their world view
the anti-mass people are being
challenged by the pro and the pro by the
ante but we're seeing the erratic
behavior almost exclusively from the
anti-vaccine and anti-mass people so
what's causing that difference that
split
yes so i guess i would say um
that okay when you're talking about a
very specific topic um
relating to the mask then you do see
that behavior on the right that you know
doesn't make sense to us as progressives
but um it can do things that uh so so
the left will uh be more um
like gung-ho about wearing masks and
like taking precautions so it's not that
it's not that extreme behavior is always
bad
extremism is bad when the ideas are
extremely stupid so you can have radical
good ideas
that can transform society and when you
have uh a situation where there's this
looming existential threat like the
pandemic it can uh catalyze civil rights
movements or it can catalyze civil wars
and uh
really when the threat is so extreme it
kind of does both those things at the
same time
so
um
going back to what you said i would
argue that uh it's not fully on the
right and in the left it manifests
itself in different ways so for example
yeah so for example um
you have the black lives matter movement
and that really exploded after the
george floyd murder and that was in may
uh just right at the beginning of the
pandemic when you know in the us
we started seeing these like warnings to
like wear masks not go outside and stuff
like that and uh that explosion that
protest like nationwide protest uh
occurred because everyone was so fearful
because of the pandemic and then you had
this like counter movement you had
people like
saying blue lives matter in response to
black lives matter and uh you know um
that was problematic didn't even make
sense because the whole point of black
lives matter was saying black lives
should matter as much as everyone else's
life so it was it was really all lives
matter from the beginning it's very
ironic that like the other side started
saying all lives matter when like that
was what the first movement was about
anyway you get this defund the police
uh movement in response to like this
right-wing blue lives matter all lives
matter thing and like that
uh slogan like his very extremes and now
i see political campaign ads using that
slogan to scare people away from
democrats so um i would say that the
left matches the right they just do it
in completely different ways right and
that's interesting you bring up the
defund now being used against some on
the left at from the beginning i said i
don't think this is a productive slogan
and and here's why and it's very
interesting that you you point to that i
do want to get you mentioned the
amygdala hijack can you talk about what
that is so we're all on the same page
with it
yeah so basically when we go through
life we're kind of mostly on autopilot
and some studies have shown that the
famous uh lebet studies uh on free will
basically
we're programmed and we have a certain
set of beliefs and goals and we kind of
behave according to those um but a lot
of times our programmed behavior won't
be optimal so if we're fearful we might
get aggressive
when that happens there's another part
of the brain
that is responsible for kicking in and
uh producing uh rational behavior where
we analyze the situation and then we
make decisions where we're like more in
control than being controlled by our
instincts and reflexes so um the two
brain areas that are important are the
amygdala and the prefrontal cortex the
amygdala is uh involved in processing
threat and is associated with the fear
response um so when we do perceive a
threat
basically
it triggers the amygdala and then that
puts us in sort of like a
fight-or-flight mode
and then the prefrontal cortex which is
a newer part of the brain evolutionary
evolutionarily and uh that part is
supposed to calm the amygdala
and uh the problem is uh in times where
fear is super high
uh the prefrontal cortex
can't do its job because the amygdala is
just constantly being triggered um
there's also some interesting studies
that show correlations between impaired
prefrontal cortex function which uh is
responsible for this uh we call it
cognitive control or executive control
right regulating regulating your
emotions and um so we see
impaired
executive control with uh people who are
uh
religious fundamentalists or we see it
with people who score high on surveys of
racism um we see it in people with drug
addiction
so basically those people are less in
control you could say they have less
free will because they're unable to
override this uh programming and uh this
uh effect that you have when um
basically the amygdala hijacks
uh the cognitive system so
what we can do about that is become
aware of that and simply becoming aware
having what's called meta awareness can
give you um control over that and then
there are exercises you can do like
practicing mindfulness um to kind of
strengthen the prefrontal cortex because
it really is like a muscle
thinking of that i i ask this not to
excuse morally ethically or legally the
actions of the january sixth writers but
i ask it in order to try to understand
is it a type of situation where you're
in this mass of people and someone
decides to start busting down doors or
breaking windows and going in
is is it possible that you sort of
experience an amygdala hijack there and
you just kind of are riding high and
carried in and participating not because
you went intending to do that but
because the situation around you sort of
puts you into that state is that a
situation where this happens
definitely and uh i would like to say
that um it's really important to
understand these people because we don't
understand the mindset
we'll have
we'll be completely lost um
in terms of how to get through to them
so when you talk about empathy for these
people um it's not so much about like
wanting to be a better human being to
have
empathy for them it's really more about
uh being practical um
finding a solution to the problem so uh
these people just like you said uh
during like uh the capital attack um
they're tuned into social media they're
plugged into the people who are stoking
that fear constantly um they're uh
responding to the others around them and
things that are happening in real time
and so you kind of get this collective
effect where it's like
the amygdala hijack is kind of like
spreading from person to person and once
that happens if there's not someone that
comes out and says hey everybody like
this is kind of crazy right um it's just
gonna snowball
is is mob mentality kind of a layman's
term for group amygdala
hijack yes definitely um it's related to
that it's also related to tribalism um i
didn't go into terror management theory
i know we talked about it last time um i
could talk about that a little bit in
relation to like this mob mentality
yeah i would be interested in hearing
that because i mean what we're you know
many of us are starting to say
is this going to happen again how likely
are these folks who in some online
spaces are saying
if we don't get x it's going to be time
for
january 6 part 2 or or whatever
i think it would be important to
understand what it is that could could
get them there but also what could
prevent it
yeah absolutely so um
i think to uh prevent it i think to get
a understanding of what's actually going
on we have to understand uh terror
management theory so uh terror
management theory um starts with the
fear of death so at some point in the
evolutionary uh development of man or
human i should say um we became
intelligent enough uh to be aware of our
own mortality right that someday we're
going to inevitably die
and uh
uh be gone and possibly forgotten and um
that uh
realization can be paralyzing
if you don't have a psychological
mechanism for coping with that
so when that happened that necessitated
the invention of cultural worldviews
like religions political ideologies
national identities uh cultural world
views basically act as death anxiety
buffers by giving us a sense of purpose
and meaning in life um
actually they um are said to offer paths
to immortality so a religion
excuse me um religion offers a path to
uh literal immortality through the
concept of an afterlife and uh national
identities uh offer a path to what's
called symbolic immortality through um
feeling like you're part of this bigger
movement this bigger idea that will
outlive the individual
um so
what terror management theory says
is that if cultural world views are how
we deal with existential fear than in
times when there's some existential
threat looming or we're reminded of our
death for some other reason we are going
to cling to our cultural world views
more we're going to become more tribal
and we're going to become more
aggressive towards people who have
different world views so really it
explains tribalism um world it's
interesting because world views
basically uh you needed some sort of
world view to emerge to have human
civilization because it's what binds
people together under a common idea but
at the same time if you have people in
different parts of the world uh
different cultural world views are going
to emerge so the thing that unites
people within the group is the very same
thing that can um that divides people
into tribes
um so one of the ways to deal with this
is to look at your different world views
look at what you have in common like for
example look at the things that the
right are complaining about and they're
fearful about that are valid now there
are going to be a lot of things that
aren't valid a lot of crazy things that
just have nothing to do with reality but
there are going to be some things that
are legitimate concerns things that they
care about um and we try to align
interest at that point um and if we can
do that we can start to
create uh some sort of unifying world
view and we really need to do that
consciously it doesn't happen by
accident so there will be a second
capital
attack something not necessarily at the
capitol but something that's like that
right uh
we're headed there and if we don't do
something very
uh consciously to change that trajectory
uh i would predict that it will happen
for sure
so would i so would i uh we've been
speaking with bobby azarian who's a
cognitive neuroscientist blogger for
psychology today and also writes the sub
stack road to omega
bobby it's always great having you on i
appreciate it great david can i mention
um the road to omega project so yes uh
that's that's really um
uh what me and some colleagues and
friends and allies have uh started to
design which just sets out a solution
for all this so everything we talked
about problem of tribalism understanding
that um a bayesian reasoning system a
logical reasoning reasoning system to
fight misinformation and conspiracy
theories and uh that plan is up at uh
road to omega.substance.com
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay let's start with
the story i was hoping to get to
yesterday didn't have time it's sort of
like rounding out the anti-vaxx police
officer that died of kovid who was on
ivermectin the anti-vaxx another
anti-vaxx right-wing radio host who died
of kovid
this is the anti-mask militia dude
who has died of
kovid um his name uh was caleb wallace
caleb wallace anti-mask organizer and
co-founder of the san angelo freedom
defenders
has died of covid19 this is a really sad
story caleb wallace
co-founder of san angelo freedom
defenders and west texas minutemen state
coordinator
has died from causes related to covet 19
according to an update on gofundme by
his wife jessica wallace caleb has
peacefully passed on
he will forever live in our hearts and
minds
reads the most recent update
this is from the
stay-at-home mom of three
expecting a fourth child
late next month
while wallace has become a secular had
become a semi-regular feature in local
news through his conservative activism
it was his battle with covid that
garnered the national spotlight after
his family's struggle was featured in an
article published in the san angelo
standard times on august 22nd
his organization of the freedom rally a
protest against state and local mass
requirements during the summer of 2020
made him a figure of some prominence
among those in the community who were
opposed to mass mandates the new york
times reports san angelo mayor brenda
gunter commented in an interview they
believed the coronavirus was a hoax and
they believed the government was being
too heavy-handed when it came to masks
yahoo news reports on this as well
texas anti-mask freedom rally organizer
fighting for his life with covet 19.
this was just a friday before he died
at that time his wife jessica wallace
wrote that she had a heartbreaking
update quote he's not doing good it's
not looking in our favor his lungs are
stiff due to the fibrosis
they called and said they've run out of
options for him
and asked if i would consent to a do not
resuscitate and it would be up to us
when to stop treatments my heart just
can't i can't imagine my life without
him at the time the 30 year old wallace
had been unconscious ventilated and
heavily sedated
um in july of 2020 he reportedly
organized a freedom rally to be against
government control of our lives
they hosted a separate rally under the
san angelo freedom defenders last year
to quote end covered tyranny
he um i mean listen it's what what what
else is there to say you know
um here is video of caleb wallace saying
covet guidelines make no sense
and kovid's just fine to live with just
live with it
the basic
rights of
breathing free air moving about freely
going into businesses without being
harassed about a mask or about
you know these doctors
levying these
ridiculous restrictions upon its
citizens with no representation in
city council commissioners courts as
judge d floyd nowhere to be found on
this
so
we our group people we're not just a
bunch of angry people we're people that
yes we are fed up but we also want to
provide options and provide
a positive option and
with this rally this is important to
us as a group because
we have to start
making changes now reverse the trend
back to normalcy back before march 2020
and what we're seeing
now is people were scared
people we were kind of unsure what this
was all about we were being fed
stuff from the top saying hey this is
this is super dangerous
and
you know we were we're all kind of
unsure i mean rightly so
but the science is out there and it's
saying otherwise that
this is perfectly fine to live with it's
deadly to certain people
but we another never in the history of
this country we've locked down healthy
people with the sick and as i mentioned
his wife is due with their fourth child
on september 27th
a pregnant wife and three
young kids
now of course you can be vaccinated and
die that can happen
it is very unlikely
that a 30 year old vaccinated individual
would have died if he had gotten the
free vaccine that is now widely
available
at basically any pharmacy
if this story doesn't convince people
i don't think anything will
and just think back to some of those
trump rallies i remember it's like
burned into my mind there was a trump
rally and we were covering it before it
started and there was like a sort of
scan of the crowd and there was a woman
maybe you know 60ish
with a shirt on and the back of the
shirt had on it
my son died of covid
and i'm still here at the rally this was
before vaccines were even available this
was like the summer last summer
um i think that there are millions and
millions of people
who are just beyond reach that's it
there's no way around it and
this is a tragic story
at least as far as these kids are
concerned you can say whatever you want
about listen caleb wallace chose not to
get vaccinated
the kids didn't choose to have an idiot
dad who was going to refuse to get
vaccinated
a vaccine that's free and likely would
have would have prevented him from dying
not a hundred percent but likely would
have prevented him from dying the kids
didn't choose that
and now they grow up without a father
and this fourth baby about to be born in
late september
is born
and will have no dad
because of this guy's mistaken beliefs
think whatever you want about him and we
can talk about should we feel bad for
for the the individuals who choose not
to get the vaccine or not and are they
victims of misinformation or are they
bad people or are they both or we don't
know
but the kids aren't guilty of anything
and um it is just if this doesn't
convince people
i truly don't know what will
let's go from something horrifying
to something really great we need some
good news my friends
ladies and gentlemen
we got em after much toil and struggle
just kidding i sit in front of a camera
in an air-conditioned room but after
many years
and many videos that's more accurate
the david pakman show youtube channel
has reached
1
billion views that's billion with a b
yes a b
now i do have a little secret to tell
you this is kind of anti-climactic but i
i might as well mention it because it's
interesting
uh on youtube
the public number of views
is based on videos that are still
published
and public okay
because we've had
a few big videos get taken down over
time because of copyright claims
because we use unlisted videos for our
member only videos
we actually hit a billion views
internally several weeks ago
but in terms of the publicly viewable
videos that are still online today it
happened late last night or early this
morning last night i tweeted guys we're
like 140 000 views away and by this
morning we had gotten there 1 billion
youtube views this is a really big
accomplishment it puts us in the top
tiny tiny slice of all youtube channels
some people are saying that that first
billion is the toughest but we are now
vue
billionaires on youtube
one other note just be things it's the
youtube channel has just been killing
lately
i know many people write to me they say
david your show is circling the drain
they've been saying that for a decade
it's actually bigger than ever another
really exciting milestone we got our
first single video with 10 million views
recently uh our top videos right now
again with 10 million views from 2011
man stands on seven hour flight because
of obese passenger
second most viewed video from 2013 six
and a half million views called
this is what happens when you wear a
nazi uniform in court
that that was a hell of a story from
2013 6.3 million views girl makes racist
comment to footballer he calls her out
from 2011 5.5 million views anonymous
hacks westboro baptist church a real
tentpole moment in david pakman show
history
then from 2012 just a hair under 5
million views soldier attacking
protester at funeral
from 2020 4.7 million views trump
humiliated and worst interview in
history that's that epic viral a
jonathan swann axios video um and then
from 2017
4.7 million views racist woman harasses
muslim shopper in trader joe's i
remember there's something avocado
related in that video i think it's that
the racist woman
in the video has a shopping cart and is
in line to pay
but only has a bag of avocados that is
really unusual grocery store behavior if
i'm buying one item
i don't get a cart especially if it's a
relatively light item like a bag of
avocados okay now interestingly due to
the nature of the content three
of our top seven videos of all time are
completely demonetized
uh not complaining just telling you how
crazy the situation is all right so
thank you for a billion views
subscribe let's get to 1.5
million subscribers and on to the next
billion views and remember that you can
also subscribe to our second channel
with unique live stream and behind the
scenes content at youtube.com
pacmanlive
so it's the two channels youtube.com the
david pakman show billion views almost
1.4 million subscribers and then
separately
youtube.com pacmanlive exciting new
things going on there we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
david p we will be accepting
congratulations for a billion views
through the weekend
i don't even know what i'm talking about
you obviously we accept congratulations
anytime here's an interesting voicemail
with just a really specific logistical
question how much are people spending
for pillows because those my pillow ones
are pretty damn expensive
have you ever noticed how expensive the
my pillow
pillows are right
you can get a pillow like that for five
bucks at
walmart
that's probably better
yeah
oh i guess that's it okay uh i have no
idea how much of my pillow costs
um i know people who spend a lot of
money on pillows 150 200 bucks and the
pillows are
tailored for this that or the other
thing i'm just an old-fashioned goose
feather pillow guy
i like a firm goose feather pillow um
there's like a two pack that i buy off
of the internet
um for like 50 bucks two pack for 50
bucks beautiful perfect pillow for me
the people saw it they said sir this is
an absolutely perfect pillow for for
both reading and uh for sleeping and
that's that's what i need i have no idea
how much the my pillows cost but it
seems to be making mike lindell a lot of
money
um we have a great bonus show planned
for you today china
is announcing a limit on children's
online gaming to just three hours a week
is this good is it an authoritarian
dystopian fiasco which is it is it both
we will talk about that secondly
you might if you drive in the united
states be used to only unleaded gasoline
of course i mean it always says unleaded
um but algeria was still using leaded
gasoline but no more the world has now
rid itself of leaded gasoline
why did it take so long and what's the
history of that and lastly
after getting hit with a category 4
hurricane new orleans is facing weeks of
power outages i have been to new orleans
in the summer
it is not a place you want to be
without power
in the summer and therefore without air
conditioning we will talk about what's
going on there um on today's bonus show
get instant access i invite you to sign
up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code better21 if
you would like and if you would prefer
to join via patreon instead of on our
website you can go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and get access to the
very same bonus show i will see you then
we are here all week otherwise tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman